all right the mvp race has been very
compelling this year at one point it
looked like it was russell wilson's and
only his he was going to go from having
no votes in his career to
all of them this year now he has
plummeted
patrick mahomes and aaron rodgers have
taken over mahomes though
has seen his number dipped from -500
which means you got to bet 500 to win
100
to minus 286. aaron rodgers on the other
hand
his odds are shrinking plus 185 from
plus 460 last week so
it's down to these two guys a huge gap
between rogers and josh allen chris
there are plenty of guys at plus ten
thousand though and that's the guy that
i'm intrigued by because derek henry at
plus ten thousand
unchanged from last week when he had 215
yards
in the win over jacksonville you would
think that would shrink the odds a bit
uh he if he can play the rest of the way
like he played on sunday gets very
interesting because if he can find a way
and i think he needs 191 yards per game
only 191 per game
191 per game over the last three weeks
gives him 21.05 which is significant
because it's the single season rushing
record if he
gets it or gets close to it how does he
not get mvp votes chris so
we're we've focused on mahomes and
rogers just like in 2012 we were focused
on peyton manning
and then here came adrian peterson with
the late push
i just think that if if henry can keep
it going
and and it is a big if but if anyone in
the nfl can do it it's derek henry
man he could end up stealing this thing
and somebody who puts 100 bucks on him
now could be walking away with 10 grand
three weeks from well it wouldn't be
three weeks from now obviously that
doesn't
get announced until the night before the
super bowl but the haze in the barn and
the votes are cast three weeks from now
well come on daddy warbucks put your
money where your mouth is throw some
throw some change down and do it come on
you're very rich
i would rather i would rather not lose a
hundred dollars than win ten thousand
wow okay
all right i mean i don't know i mean
it's pretty good odds for you it's your
guy but either way
it is semi intriguing because of two
reasons
the lions and the texans they are not
good on run defense
he could he could pile on a game of 180
or another 200 yard
day against one of those two teams
there's no doubt about it
and then the packers being that third
team on the schedule are not great on
run defense either
so he is going to have i think a legit
chance to maybe flirt with 2 000. i
don't know if he can get to 2100 and the
all-time record and all that but either
way i'm with you
he deserves to be more talked about in
the conversation
and for me when you just talk about the
pure essence of mvp
you know yeah it mahomes rogers josh
allen
and derrick henry they they they are the
epitome of that and i think that
that makes a lot of sense but i'd like
to see him flirt with that 2000 and get
close
that titan's packers game coming up
weeks i know on sunday night football
holy crap i know right my goodness i
mean
we've got three regular seasons games
left we've got brown's giants this
weekend which will be great it'll be fun
to see the browns again in prime time
right after we saw the exciting game on
monday night then titans packers and
then
a game that has some significance
whatever it is it always kind of shakes
out we'll know the playoff play in game
maybe there's a chance it'll be brown
steelers maybe there's a chance it'll be
washington and who do they play the last
week is it the eagles if the eagles keep
winning maybe that'll be maybe that'll
be the game for the nfce so
uh yeah some good games coming up in
prime time and that's the other thing
i wanted to say this earlier as it
relates to the significance of what we
saw
yeah go ahead last night was the perfect
time to have a game like that because
think of how much it increases the
anticipation
of the final three weeks the regular
season even if the final three weeks
don't
deliver last night was the thing that
just pushes it all to a higher level
and we're all going to be more
interested and we're all going to be
more locked in and we're all waiting for
that next game that makes us feel like
we felt watching the game last night
you know when the chiefs rams had their
game a couple of years ago it was right
before thanksgiving
we've seen other great games early in
the year remember there was a thursday
night game between the rams and the
49ers a couple of years ago that no one
expected it was a great game
this is the perfect time to have a great
game going into this kick
uh down the stretch for the various
teams and uh i
i just think it's perfect for the nfl
it's perfect for us as fans
and as broadcasters talking about the
game every day i just think it really
adds to the overall excitement that
we're going to be experiencing the rest
of the month
yeah well it does you know it's the
playoff stretch it's the greatest time
of the year
and man i mean we got a lot of good
teams you know like we've talked about
there's going to be some really good
football teams that miss out on the
playoffs this year
it has been a very top-heavy you know uh
type of football season but i would be
shocked if we're not delivered more
moments like we saw
last night i mean the season is
delivered on the field more times than
not
and i think we got some great matchups
we did that draft last week of matchups
we're most excited for the last few
weeks of the year and
man we couldn't have had enough rounds
there was a lot of games that are
awesome matchups so
it should be good here so the top two
candidates for mvp oh thy aaron rodgers
padron homes and aaron rodgers and and
the reason that patrick mahomes numbers
dipped he had the three interceptions
and aaron rodgers
wins the division even though they
didn't cover unfortunately
that was one of my best bets i was one
and two in my best bets the only thing
worse than that would be oh and three
which you were yes but that's okay i
don't care we don't it's funny we don't
care we make our pictures
i don't care i mean i do our best and we
move on yeah but uh
yeah i mean i i deal with having a bad
week by saying i don't care when i have
a great week i do care when i have a bad
week i don't care
uh who would you put your money on
between mahomes and rogers factoring in
the odds knowing that you got a bet
right now you got about 286 to win 100
if you pick mahomes a hundred gets you a
185 if you pick roger
well i i mean
mahomes is the leader in the clubhouse
right now as it stands
i don't think leader house leader house
he's in the leader house
that there's no doubt i don't think he
should be
i'll say it again i think aaron rodgers
is the mvp of football
this year i do it's very close but
i think when you consider the supporting
cast and everything like that and then
you talk about the numbers and
you know just how he's pulled them
through in a lot of big moments and just
really
been consistent all year yeah i would
give it to him
um but i just feel like it's gonna go
mahomes way
unless he has one more game like the
other day and i just don't know if
that's going to happen
you know i don't see the falcons and
chargers giving an issue to the kansas
city chiefs
maybe the saints this weekend you know
get their edge back and cause some
problems but
if you made me bet money i'd bet on my
homes only for the pure money purpose
but my football eye tells me that aaron
rodgers the mvp this year
the thing that i love and hate about the
mvp
vote is there's no definition there
never is what does it mean most valuable
to his team
best player in the league it's become de
facto best player in the league
and then you've got this weird
compromise that happens with
mvp and offensive player of the year
sometimes it's two different guys like
it's the consolation prize
the drew brees offensive player of the
year award he's never won mvp but he's
been offensive player of the year at
least once maybe more than once
for racking up all those numbers he's
just what do you really it's
a very visceral thing and and chris
i say this all the time until we know
the one seeds i think having the one
seed is a factor
in who gets this if the chiefs of the
one seed
and the packers aren't it skews much
more strongly toward mahomes
if the packers get the one seed and the
chiefs don't
it's gonna skew toward rogers that's why
even though we talk about it and the
odds change every week and it's fun and
it's part of just this all
this flavor of covering a season until
the final standings are locked in
and you know who's sitting where on the
playoff tree it's impossible to know
with any certainty
who that favorite really is so what if
they're both one seeds though
right like what it's gonna be i think
it's gonna be my homes i think it's
gonna be my homes
but okay let's consider this yeah when
do we see
mahomes in a big spot the rest of the
year do they have any nationally
televised games down the stretch they
their week 17 game i think is against
the chargers that's not going to be
the saints game this weekend it's the
biggest game on facebook
okay so we got the saints that's that's
i'm talking about prime time yeah
4 25 p.m eastern big spot on a sunday
and then the next week you've got aaron
rodgers
making his closing argument i mean
that's really what this is if it's going
to be
a close race for the 50 votes the
closing argument
for patrick mahomes purposes is this
weekend against the saints
closing argument for aaron rodgers
purposes is next weekend
against the titans yeah i i think you're
you're probably right i mean i i do and
yeah
this could really kind of set up that
way i think it could come down to those
two games
the saints even with that game too let's
not forget rogers went into new orleans
and had a big day and beat them i wonder
if that plays into this too
but yeah we've seen mahomes a little
careless with the ball there
saints are going to be pissed off but if
he goes out
you're right i think it has like a just
a plays a great game like we basically
see him do most games
and they win it probably will close the
door
unless just rogers does something
miraculous down the stretch the one good
thing about rogers is the titans coming
to town on the sunday night football
game
not a great pass rush not a great pass
defense
he could light up disguise that night
and put up a huge statistical number
that
you know can maybe make things
interesting so it'll be fun to watch
it's it's the it's the two best in the
sport that's for sure and that's cool
that we're talking about it right now
and here's one final wrinkle about the
mvp process that
that needs to be said and this isn't the
first time i've said it
i'm going to say it again it's
ultimately determined by 50 people
from the media world and and the list
isn't
easily available but you can you can
find the list if you look hard enough
and it changes every year
let me just say this there are people
who have a vote
who should not period i'm not going to
name names
there are people who have a vote for
those awards who
should not have it these are the ap
awards they should not have it i won't
name names i will say this chris
you and i both should there are
multiple who do that don't that's for
the ap to deal with and the fact that
i'm
saying it means i'm not playing the
political game that would be necessary
to get it
i don't care i'm here to speak the truth
not kiss ass
there are people who have those votes
that shouldn't and if these
awards are going to be legitimate chris
guys like you and i who cover the entire
league
every day of our lives should is there
anything wrong with me saying that i i
don't think so i've i've always had a
little bit of a a problem with that i i
have
you know i i don't know what to say you
know i can read and write it doesn't
mean i get to write for the best
vote for the best writers in the world
either so i don't know i think
technically we could say i know
more about reading and writing than some
of these guys do about football to your
point
but yet they're getting to make
life-changing votes on it too
i don't understand that totally and
that's no disrespect and we're not
saying to everybody because we know it
is disrespectful well it's disrespectful
right right but there's a lot that we
don't respect that we
think that right know what's going on
and and follow the league just as
closely as we do
but this is only 50. yeah this isn't
500.
and they need to do a better job of
picking the 50 period and and i know in
the past there have been
voters who cover one team if you cover
one team how in the hell
can you even begin to make broad
judgments league wide you can't validate
you just
can't if you cover one team you're right
it's impossible
what's gonna happen is you're gonna rely
on somebody else that you trust who has
a vote hey who are you voting for
that's who they're gonna vote for that's
how it goes so anyway that's i just
every year i need to get that off my
chest this isn't something i just need
to get off my chest
once every i just have to purge those
feelings
okay not that it's ever going to get me
the vote maybe i'll help you get the
vote
they're never going to get it to me
because i'm the jerk who's willing to
say that their panel stinks
well not all of it just some of it you
feel good you're good you're good we've
got 16 days
left in the year so it's the last time i
want to hear it okay good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports